he was six foot five with a bolo tie and
a face that was downright punch there
with you stub up setters hosted a
flippin soccer practice nobody respects
us with a GT front motors for nancy
walker helen kiss my tuchus I'm staying
here yeah okay let's leave hey if you
all could just behave I'll buy LG french
fries the folk guard fudge the offseason
I won't break it football win this for
me son Pro Bowls and memories that's all
you got ah watch it Brady stop me for me
to GTA Joe ever calm down geez get it
losers clown not gonna put to get me San
Diego Alif bargain dome I can't frickin
believe we gotta save the GD day again
okay well Larry he's clearly a
hall-of-famer a light has to ring that
fails consistency my god Oh everyone
don't go loves you
hey 2040 lot yeah I'm a hall-of-famer to
my friend the fluff is a charger anyone
hey you yeah I'll freakin hundred
thousand to you flippin listen to me
I'll be out about the MF and lurkers
watching RBS so subscribe this cheating
Chandler GT the fluff Oh daddy says
subscribe